building self-driving car has been the
dream of my life and I've dedicated more
than 10 years to it if we can build a
safer car we would save a lot of lives
but on top of it it's transformational
just imagine instead of owning a car you
have a little phone in your summoner car
and MP car comes to you years
jump in and lets you go somewhere and
when you don't need anymore
it disappears there is an enormous
market for self-driving car engineers
lots and lots of companies that you
wouldn't suspect have ended that feed
and are massively hiring I challenge
everybody here to be part of this we're
launching a Udacity a nano degree
program called self-driving car so that
everyone in the world can become a
self-driving car engineer